okay hello everybody my name is Ronnie
Solomon I'm a software engineer and
Microsoft worked there since 17 years so
almost too much I say first thing I need
to apologize I ran into an issue and I
really tried out all night to fix it but
didn't make it and the problem is my
accent I'm from the Italian speaking
part of sweets right this line is around
Italian accent so when I say like we fee
means Wi-Fi and things like this so the
good news for you always tend to do a
lot of demos so you can at least take a
look at the demo the slides those are
kind of in kind of English style but
again I didn't fix it and sorry for that
good so this session is about IOT IO
teenager laura1 and depends a bit on Al
you know those technology I think I have
a bit for everybody so from the basic to
a bit more deep dive in this technology
so let's start
what is laura1 is a wide area network
technology and the main goal is to have
a long range and really low power
consumption the main design is to be
able to run on battery for a long long
time so no cable no power so that's it
the big things it's not meant to be on a
power angry or really big kind of
devices it's really meant to go long
range low power so how much long range
it depends it goes for a few kilometers
in a city to 20 kilometer outside in a
rural place to line-of-sight you can
easily go to 100 kilometer so that's
pretty powerful so compared to Wi-Fi and
other technology you get a lot a lot of
range and some sensor that are not
really chatty they can even last 10
years on battery so that's the key
combination of this technology so really
good for some IOT scenario some
particularities so there are some
providers there's even some community
were like the thing
work or some Tesco like in sweet threads
whisk um provide 95% of the population
already F Laura coverage but the good
things in my opinion about Laura and
Laura one you can create your own
network you can buy a gateway and you
have a network so I said we are not
there yet but in theory is like buying
our Wi-Fi router plug it in and you get
a network so that's the cool thing there
all the technology that is not there is
bi-directional although there are some
limitation there but you can send
message to the Laura device and you can
receive message from Laura device it's
low bandwidth and when I mean low it
means really low so is no other typo is
51 bytes 242 bytes so if you had the
idea oh let's put to Laura device and I
stream Netflix across the border does
not the technology good for because your
movie will take couple of years to get
there okay the idea is also it depends
on many sensor you have attached for
Gateway some of the provider they put
limits if you be your own network you
can a bit play a bit more around that
you don't need to have a really chatty
device again low cost running battery is
based on up in standard there are older
technology in the same space six Fox
narrowband IOT is coming coming mostly
from the telco 6/4 they're doing their
own infrastructure and so on there are
advantages and disadvantages not my goal
to teach you which one is the better you
need to go look into the advantage of
this advant of each by the way the Oh
laser template and word that we are
doing today it applies to all three
technology so it's not really there are
some Laura specific things but it's not
really you can do exactly the same with
all three I think for me one of the key
distinction among these three technology
is the possibility to be your own
network I want to cover my manufacturing
plant I buy one gateway
I want to cover my two buildings up by
two
and so on so I mean don't need to depend
to other people to give me the
infrastructure good let's talk about
Ezra oh I know sorry what kind of sin I
you can do with Laura based devices so
this is some of the common that I find
this is a in-room present sensor so
think about you want to look at your
room or desk how many people are there
is it free or not today you need to wire
cable and so on it's very costly so the
sensor precise stupid but wiring cable
maybe even put it on the Wi-Fi network
of a enterprise try to put it a Wi-Fi
device inside Microsoft finally with a
nightmare we change the certificate is a
pain gas so this is for example so we
need ass device you plug it in II last
two three years on power on battery
power one and turning the old building
you get all your room presence don't
another one for example this trash can
is it full or not should I pass and
clean all the trash can and so on so
this is another sensor then there is the
classical GPS tracker so this is a
really small one he runs between one and
two months in battery compared to the 4G
GPS sensor is much much better in that
sense because they normally put an
accelerometer there if this movement is
sending the GPS coordinate if not not so
that's kind of things then my prefer one
if you want to track my wife that's what
I used to know is he's done for animals
so think about in Africa until some
years ago you were there ppppp you will
never find the animal now you put a
color it's an GPS coordinate 20
kilometers you go there you know exactly
where the animal is so they did with
black rhino they did an eagle project to
track the Eagle moving around and so on
as Mara metering is a classical scenario
to we have parking lot so think about if
you have a new parking lot you can cable
that but an old one just to put cable
and to have a sensor on every parking it
cost a lot but think about is the
parking lot is outside where do you put
it is you need to dig all the asphalt
and is you simply can dig a hole put
this one it lasts four to five years in
battery you know when the battery
that you simply open up change the
battery done and you know if the car is
out or not so allow you to make much
easier installation of this country the
next one is funny one pest control so
you want to know if you have rats or not
so if the rats trigger the trap pan
drizzle or a massage you know and the
next one is not yet available but it
kind of interesting is a Laura based
device with a printed battery is a label
it will cost around thirty cents if you
break the label it will transmit a
senior it doesn't have of course GPS
leader in this tiny label but view that
there is a calculation of location if
you have multiple Gateway with a time to
fly you can more or less get around 100
meter location so think about made a
important package and so on you can make
sure that it can open a destination and
not somewhere in the transit so just to
show some array of sensor and things
there are a lot of other stuff I just
picked some to represent what is
possible with this technology cool what
about a sure so Azure we have a lot of
services to build IOT solution and so on
and I will scratch the surface today we
show some of the services that we used
to be the L key solution there are many
mores but I want to show the common one
and actually the one that are quite easy
to build on top so the first one is a
bit the entry point is azure IOT R but
this is an injection mechanism and a
device management all the configuration
management or more functionality on top
of that by the main goal is to receive
and send messages be directional and so
it's a really good service to use when
you want to collect data from IOT
devices good so let's take a look at the
classical Laura scenario this is the
classical we look to some additional
scenario later so you have Laura devices
like those one darm
send into a gateway gateway sends to a
network server could be laureate could
be activity could be the ting network
could be a cloud solution could be your
own server and this server normally have
connectors and these connectors can go
to IOT up
so that's the old past that he does
bytes here by its going to the server
send it to a Yap you need the device
connected on both and that's about it so
if you want to connect the ting network
or laureate and so on you can basically
use one of the connector and send it to
a Yap so what we did you say oh now I
have the data note yup what I do with
that cool I everything like you I should
do something right and so that's what we
time came up and create a template for
starting out with Laura solution and
actually this is the template that we
have built he has some Laureus specific
stuff but is just the synchronization of
the devices you can change it rewrite it
we will publish a more generic one very
soon and then we have a complete
pipeline it's not a finished solution is
more like think about a visual studio
start template I deploy that and I can
start to work on top of that so that
exactly what I want to show it today and
of course you can even connect IP base
and not only Laura base so the same
problem works for both
there are some particularities do today
nature of Laura I will show you later
cool so the first thing that you need to
know a by the way maybe I should show
that so if I go to my browser and I go
to get up today as your solution
template you see there is the same image
and resolve the documentation I'll you
set up of you go step by step make it
run the interesting part is that if you
click this button this is an RM template
fairly complex then Waddy dasi deploy
every component and there's even some
optional component in your Azure
subscription so that's exactly what I
did I deployed this one so you go in you
set a couple of properties so mostly
password and you can say a one time
series I want power bi and I want
alarming yes or no click deploy you get
these things running on your solution so
we save a lot of time a configuring
losing time and so you can start with
that that exactly what a DD takes around
10 minutes so I thought should I waste
and minutes of your time watching a show
deployment no I give you already before
so we will use
cool so one particularities of laura's
this low-bandwidth narrowband
very small bits so you're not sending a
JSON like very chatty they send a byte
format and in there there is some Laura
specific and there is the payload maybe
a temperature and humidity so first
thing you need to decrypt because
Laura's encryption that's really good
you can normally most of the connector
they decree before that so the network
application server decree for you we
have a library we'll publish soon that
you can decrypt after ioki up so you
have a end-to-end encryption that's
pretty cool but the first thing you need
to understand is that you need to decode
because you get these bytes and you want
value temperature and so on the good
thing is that it's not that are the bad
thing there's no standards so every
sensor manufacturer come up with their
own way to package bytes right so you
need a very flexible way to decode that
right if not you end up with a total
mess so that's exactly what we built so
once you get the D 10 IOT app you need
to decode it
so from these bytes to maybe a JSON
format so you can use it later on in the
pipeline and so for that we use a as
your function our several s components
and basically we have a component that
simply say oh this sensor need this
decoder and we call this decoder we call
this decoder of HTTP so you can use
function in here but you can even have
your container somewhere else with your
own logic so if you find if the sensor
vendor just give you I don't know some
really assembly language running on a
mine frame good connect to over HTTP to
a mine frame maybe is a bit an extreme
case but just to show you of course if
you have done that JavaScript and so on
you can run it as a function cool let's
try to build this one so first thing we
want to do is I need to define a device
on IOT out so I go in my resource here I
go to my ayah chip there we go
okay perfect and now in my IOT AB you
can see I have IOT devices and my
ability devices that can add a new
device so if I want to add a new device
I got it here give it a name so Laura
device they tend to have this a UI kind
of name so this one is my device first
we start with an emulator device that we
ship in the template so people can start
working without the sensor we will use
the sensor later on I save it and now
we're missing something I need to say
which decoder I'm using for that device
so you can go in that device and there
is something called device stream the
idea of device string is to have
configuration settings and so on so it's
pretty powerful especially for ip-based
you if you change something server-side
it gets sent out to the device for Laura
we cannot do it but it's a powerful
concept so now I can put this
information there and let's put it here
and basically the only important one is
this one I say I want to use this
decoder we see with this decoder by
default but let's see how you add a new
decoder to the template so it's called
weathershield
you can even put the location of the
sensor if you installed somewhere you
can put a lot of metadata if this needs
to go through alarming or not we will
see later so let's save it so now I need
to add this decoding function so in the
template if you look at the source code
we should with already some of the
decoders so this one is for the button
so a button is very stupid if there is a
one it means that it's pressed so that's
very easy to parse with some order like
a GPS it can be quite a bit of bite
shifting around so you can see quite a
bit of code we not going through that
but just to show that it can be a
complex scene so you have all this
decoder so now I add a new one for our
specific case so at a class let's give
it a meaningful name there we go decoder
weather and now you can see me typing
I don't know it's a bit frustrating
order for me so I copy and paste the
code and explain quickly the code is
super stupid what we do here so is a
HTTP base function trigger this is the
function name and basically we get the
body we parse it as a JSON message we go
grab just data specific and basically
where do the bytes that Laureate or
whatever gateway sending me and then do
some byte shifting here
very stupid we split the two value then
and I get him I create a new object with
data temperature data humidity and I
return it back to the rocking function
so very easy small amount of code done
so let's save it and let's publish to
Azure so I go here and say publish
public to my function so I had my new
things then you could have different
function in different location as I said
you can create your own HTTP endpoint
for doing that so let's take a look that
is doing that publish started is a good
time to drink there we go publish
succeed
so now Oh Paula we got another things
here we got this simulator so the
simulator is a common line simulator
that simulate a Laura payload and
basically I create this JSON format with
the byte king here sort some pointers
the data and we pass in the hexadecimal
data and send it so right now I
configure quickly to send it to my up
and to send 1 million message is not
really the normal Laura keys that you
send every two seconds a lot of message
but for demonstration view that I don't
use any Laura radio that's good so let's
start it up
and you will see sending message how do
you know that we receiving message there
is a tool that I can use to monitor and
say look I want to monitor the specific
device and you can see I get the message
there and you see the bytes here coming
in now we want to be sure that we are
decoding that right and so I can go
my arrow porta and go look to the
function that we just deploy and monitor
that so let's see there we go
functions and we have my sensor decoder
wearer let's go to the monitor and let's
see if it's already a refreshing if not
we need just a few seconds that they
logs come in and you will see a few
second ago I got the message and you can
see I decoded the temperature and
humidity classical Laura with a lot of
numbers after the comma very useful no
just because they randomizer that we use
is a bit stupid but you get the point so
we send we received the Laura byte we go
to this routing code we do some decoding
and we run it through okay so the same
approach other than these routing stuff
that is a bit specific to Laura or
anything that is byte encoded we can use
it for any device right yup I can even
connect so we have this pretty cool MX
chip so it's Arduino board is Wi-Fi base
you have some button display and so I
connect it up already with my l.joe so
if I turn it on it will take a few
second to the wireless network and once
connected to the wireless network you
will send data to so let's go and
monitor also that one is this one and
hopefully it should be sending data
let's see forget yes and you see in this
case view that this wireless base
already sent the decoded so I say simply
skip the decoding pipeline so you can
have because that's a classical you
where maybe 20 Laura device and 200 IP
based device so you don't want to have
to IOT up to different pipeline so
that's what I wanted to show that so
this is a pretty cool kit you can win
one here at the Microsoft booth or you
can order one IC is $30 so I I found it
quite cool good so we get data Pantene
by both the simulator and this device we
go to real Laura after good
go perfect so I want to analyze data
right so now I get data on I out yup
cool what I do with this data
why do I store it and so we have virus
service to do this kind of job and in
this case one of the first service that
you can start to use is something called
a short time series inside that is a
time series database highly optimized to
do aggregation over time classical thing
tell me the month average temperature
tell me the seconds temperature and so
on and so on is also I find it a super
tool to debug and understanding what's
going on with your sensor and I could
talk an hour about that or simply do a
quick demonstration so the idea here the
template deploy on top of a van top this
time series inside functionality you
could although wire up this directly to
IOT up but remember viuda we signed
bites is hard to understand about so
that's why we were up at after the
decoding pipeline cool
so let's go in my portal and we go here
and we go and say from all the resources
that I deployed we go to this time
series inside perfect and so you can see
is wire wrapped to even top so you have
one connection today a consumer group of
the queue and if you click the portal
there is a UI so you can call to recipe
I use this UI and we are also starting
to ship javascript controls that you can
use it you can see I got some data in
here and so I can go and say oh look at
the bit less intervals and then who what
kind of data now the cool thing is view
to this JSON I can start to look into
this JSON Oh would be cool to see the
temperature right and it will be good to
see it by device and so you can see now
I have two devices one sending random
data and one sending some real data so
this is real temperature the simulator
is random you can see can go to even
lower so this is doing the aggregation
and you can see I can say all go back in
time I see a peak of data
I was testing so let's go back to that
data and you can see I can compare here
I even have the third device I can add
new chart and so on one pretty cool
things I can even look to the events
process I can go and say explore events
it will query the streaming and get back
the real value so you can go and take a
look at the single value you can decide
what property you want to see if you
want to see the battery for example you
can get the battery and so on now their
old powers is all 255 but you can do
this kind of analysis or even one cool
things that we add here we have the heat
map so you can see you there's something
strange here there are some red value I
can zoom in way and I can see for
example the deer I have quite a
temperature 33 compared to a much cooler
temperature so you can see so that's
pretty easy to use tool to dig in to
date and so on
if storing you can pay per amount of
mass such that you store a new process
so it's pretty handy tool to do that
good there we go let's continue so on
yes so it the difference for that
specific period so then you can
configure by by default he looks at the
average and so the average valor always
run 26 to 29 and suddenly there was a
peak of 33 34 is simply coloring the
range based on the distribution good so
another tool that we have is called as
your stream analytics you can use also
Apache spark if you want to and swim
analytical funding extremely easy to use
and flexible to create your IOT pipeline
because these allow you to do query move
things that and move things on databases
so you can decide all which data to
store where you maybe have some basic
telemetry data that you want to store in
a blob storage chip and you want some I
value data be storing a sequel because
your company want to query in a
classical sequel database so with
similarities you can do that very easily
there are other approach not saying
which one is better or worse as in this
one the big advantage in my opinion is
very very simple although yes some
advantage if you
look at the Python so what we are doing
here data get to stream analytics and
stream analytics start to distribute
data real-time data to power bi alive
then we get to sequel you get to cosmos
DB that I think is pretty useful for IOT
project and so on also one thing that
view that you start and you can stop and
go back in time they're really cool you
can decouple the storing from the in
queueing so if you want to do
maintenance you want to test things and
sound is pretty easy because you can
stop do some antennas restart so you
don't have a pipeline that goes through
an input keep the database without able
to stop and change thing this is the
kind of breaking point there was a queue
before event up and then you can start
to process again so I find it very
useful for that too so let's take a look
how it works there we go stream
analytics so if you go to stream
analytics here you can see it's running
and you can see I have eight outputs and
then I have a query so it was with query
and the first query I'm running is very
easy say take anything that comes in and
stoic in cosmos so let's simply get from
the queue stork in the database but you
have resume a rendering retry that's for
free one line of sequel you have done
then we say oh if it's a sensor decoded
weather send it to sequel because we
have a table only for temperature and so
on this is an example we will not use it
today then I said oh look if the
metadata contain that this is a data
useful for alarming send it to our
service bus queue for alarming so I can
do and I will explain that later and
then we'd have like the last one that is
the one I want to show now is that I say
look and here you can form a dot you say
I want only to have this value in this
format only for this specific device or
group of device send it to power bi so I
can send live stream to power bi so I
can have real-time charting without
going through a database so that's
exactly what I'm doing sending into
power bi so now if I go to my power bi
King here and I say I want to add a tile
go grab this live streaming data
this one is the live data and I want a
line chart and the axis should be the
time and here there should be the value
I want my temperature next next let's
make it a bit bigger there we go
so now yeah I don't want to create a
phone you perfect you got the
temperature so I'll you know that I'm
not fooling you because I can put my
finger here and hopefully the
temperature will go up and up and up so
you can see Ashley is going down so I'm
cooler and that should not be the case
so or I'm dying or but something happens
so that's cool I have another more
foolproof system that putting my finger
probably I'm swaggin cold for the
session so that's why but you see it
slowly getting to a body temperature
okay so pretty easy to do get data from
the cue to stream and I fix to power bi
so as you can have interactive charts
and in this case real-time charts cool
additionally what we are doing is stream
analytics you can do even aggregates so
think about I want to store already the
aggregates I don't want to have the
second level I want to have an average
every 2 minutes I don't want to have
that specific details store in a sequel
because I will consume a lot of
resources for something that I don't
need that level of details so I do that
so I want just to show you how I can
change go and change
they swim analytics engine perfect so
let's go back to my not the slides
actually I want to go back to stream
analytics and first thing I want to do I
want to go to cosmos at other new
collection I want to have a collection
only for aggregates so I can go to
cosmos and say look I want a new
collection and let's type in the name
because I'm quite terrible in typing so
I will not do mistake and then wondering
you can choose unlimited storage viewed
and I'm cheap and my manager is paying
my assure subscription I take the fixed
one take this lowest one
so one cents a day should be no
so she will approve my proceeding and so
basically you will create a new
collection so collection is the kind of
sets like DB if you want you can
contain so you can have multiple
collection every collection of partition
and so on so in this case already have
three one were the old sensor data goes
in and one when I want to put the
aggregates so now I need to go and
change stream analytics
so I go to stream analytics top the job
you need to stop to do changes and you
can see I get the outputs so now I can
add a new outputs as soon as stop stream
analytics so now is a bit of a quiz here
how many people as working as well to
create this template and the answer are
four because there is four styles of
naming right so you can see we really
need to fix this one is really ugly but
anyway so let's get the job stopped we
add a new output and we add a new query
that goes to the output so as soon as
the job is stopping so it is good
because I can breathe while talking you
will come here and I can add a new
output see so let's let it stop quickly
and so me stop I can even show already
the query so I can save some time so
this will be the query that I'm sending
instrumentality I say look I want to get
the a UI so the device name the amount
of rows that compose this aggregate so
it's an aggregates over ten rows or 100
rows because I can do some validation
there then I get the average temperature
average of humidity the time stamp goes
to this output so it goes to cosmos from
event app and then here say only for
weather shield type of data and here is
the interesting part tumbling windows
every two minutes so what it does the
tumbling windows we have also sliding
windows or any windows but in this case
twelve - twelve - twelve - - twelve four
and so on so it does a two minutes
aggregate okay so that's very easy so
now let's take the query copy the query
perfect
we go here we are the new destination
and it will be sure I should have copied
the name that's quickly because I know I
will miss type so I go in at a new
output any role the output available
from stream analytics I pick up cosmos
say the awliyas pick one that already my
subscription already existing database
the collection name that I'm using safe
I am a new output perfect and now I can
go back to my stream analytics edit the
query passed in an additional query and
change the completing so you can see in
a fairly few step I create a new
collection change my query change my
output and Don so that's the beauty of
stream analytics is very very simple two
things if you are really American Plex
pipeline and so on maybe spark is better
but to start work on this kind of things
I find it very easy note cluster to
manage nothing is a platform service
service so you can see you don't need to
manage anything you can change the
performance even in more or less
instances and so on so pretty cool let's
save it perfect and once it's saved I
can start again the job cool so you
should trust me it works
no I wish this later but it takes couple
of minutes to get the aggregates so
let's move to a next topic and then come
back and check the data here cool so
let's go back to my slide deck oh yeah
that one I wanted to show so we also add
another thing so instrumentality you see
that I have also when I create a device
I said if I want alarming true or false
so I can use stream analytic as a
gatekeeper and say oh if data is coming
from a device that I set alarming true
it means this data needs to go also to a
queue that goes to an alarming system so
it goes to a service bus queue and then
from there you can pick it up and do
your own logic in our case we decided to
add an example using logic up it's a
workflow system that we have in air
that is easy to use and create rules
like Oh connect to a sleepy then Bucca I
don't know buy a new hardware because
your ass berry pies dying
so whatever logic you want to create on
top of that so it's really easy to
customize alarming is not one solution
fits all is I think an easy solution to
allow at alarming it depends from the
scale of alarming and so on you can pick
it if it's the right or not so let's go
and add alarming on top of that so the
default template that you get there we
go let's go here and go to this one we
keep it we go to the logic up here so
there we go
logic up and we can go quickly to the
example that we publish and edit that
one so the example that we publish is
say when we receive a message on this
topic on this alarming topic parse the
JSON go find out if there is a
temperature above 30 degrees and then
compose check if already notify more
than 10 times and then if not what I do
and if you want to send an alarm what
action and if I add the action here you
can see is loading all the action from
the things and you can see we have a bit
of everything so from Creative Cloud to
all the azure service to really we have
a lot db2 tons of tons Excel whatever
you want to in this case let's start
simple I want to send an email go in
send an email so I need to pick up two
to send it in this case will be myself
Microsoft calm and then I can specifies
subjects I said device equal and take
the a UI so I know which device and I
say in the body temperature as reach it
and just put a dot point and go and pick
if I have a temperature value there we
go maybe add some more things on it I
say importance should be I
is an alarm and that's it so I save it
and then if now I get more than thirty
degree it will start sending me emails
so just a simple pipeline to show how
from a Laura based device or a wireless
based device I can get into that cool so
let's check that it really works let's
add this chart here so how do I get
thirty degree
try amid my finger but I'm a bit running
cold right now
so that's why I have a gaming notebook
I'm not a gamer but he produced a lot of
heat so if I take my device here and I
put it here see see I finally find a
scope and why is going down if you go up
I was going up is going up twenty five
twenty hearts and finally we reached our
key yeah so now let's see if my pipeline
works and I can go in my image thingy
and let's see if they come in the
messages they should come if I didn't do
any mistake some wondering if these
things is telling some if the filtering
is working or you should get some send
me me did I save it did I do something
wrong
yeah the mo that's why doing live things
probably mistype something I have only
895 unread email so I can quickly check
oh there we go they come in so you see
and it's the one from now right so just
to see 458 right so just that I prove
right not faking so see our simple to do
that although we said we use three
monolithic s'right and I'm doing
aggregate so view that the demo kind of
works let's track if the aggregates also
works so I can go back to my data
Explorer I go to the aggregate
collection look if I have documents in
it and you can see I have some documents
and if you check I will have one for one
device the emulator and one for the
wireless based device you can see with
the aggregate and our
euros are part of this aggregation you
can see there's always 1454 and then
probably have a 1456 and then I have
probably a 1458 okay so you can see how
easy I can do aggregation on live
streaming data and saving and so on so
now I saved the senior and in one table
and the aggregate because maybe in the
long term I keep the aggregate I delete
the senior because think about IOT tends
to with Laura not because there are so
chatty but you tend to produce the
answer amount of data so the first thing
to understand is the cost of storing
what kind of data you will be processing
out it's very easy to gather incredible
they are discussing the cost of IOT up
no that's not the problem ingestion is
never the problem or you au jus judge
amount of censored anomalies the data
after 1 year 2 year 10 years so that's
the classical things they can see cool
so we have done that so that's a bit of
a tour of our template you can see you
can take it you can create an account to
laureate plug it in by your own device
your own get values the simulator start
to play around it's all released we will
publish a generic version that you can
plug it into whatever network provider
you're using so that's pretty cool easy
as you can see is a good starting point
to learn it's not a final solution is
just to say build a solution top we give
you a starting point ok so that's this
thing cool so now we can kill the
simulator and I can unplug my wireless
because I'm not using I want to maybe
you know people I came to see Laura and
these guys using a simulator or no-risk
right now I know I will show you I take
even more if that's why I do it at the
end cool so I lost my mouse or it's gone
this may be too warm the PC right cool
so we have another technology that will
soon come out so I'm sure you doing
everything on the cloud is absolutely
great
for a lot of scenarios great but for
some order maybe it's not the best case
or maybe you want boss let's think about
I have temperature my notebook is
getting hotter and hotter what is the
answer when is too hot you shut it down
right so think about if I do all in the
cloudy means I send a message up do the
analysis so it's too hot send the
comment down to any other device to shut
it down why I want to do that I depend
on the WHA on the network and son maybe
you don't even have network maybe you
have some problems so you want to maybe
do some processing at the edge so I can
do some logic down to a machine that is
really running on the manufacturing plan
I don't whatever is the use case or even
ammo by I want to have it on a
helicopter on a truck and so on so
that's all it kind of scenario that I
oth a mentor onto so what is IOT edge
it's coming very soon we have a preview
now so I use the preview bits and the
idea is to run containers on top of a
device so the device run modules those
module can talk can have stream
analytics in there can have machine
learning as a queue so I can start to
queue up things if I don't ask
connection of intermittent I don't
cannot pronounce that I said my English
is poor in accent
so if I have connection going in and
back he has a cue system he has a
security system and science is pretty
pretty cool about that
so why I'm talking about IOT edge on a
Laura King and here is where the things
start to be a bit fun we have done some
experimental work and the idea is okay
so now so stop here quickly what i shun
till now is all release you can use it
they want that we are doing is
experimental we will publish in a month
or so that you can play around it's done
meant to run in production okay just to
be clear that people don't struggle I
take it run it because it's really early
so this is the case that we presented
right you need multiple gateway does
gateway connect to an adverse server
that you buy or the network provider so
if you go to a tail call you paper
message whatever you pay
you can message into IOT hub and sod
it's cool especially if you have a lot
of gateway a lot of devices or if you're
roaming across you want to track track
across Norway that's a good thing you
want somebody I provide an Edward but
what about if I have 20 censoring my
manufacturing plant I have my ranch with
horses I want to check if all gates are
closed or not I don't have a range by
the way so I have small more apartment
but anyway assuming that ever ends with
horses I want to track if the gate are
open or not and things like this so that
is can we do a much simplified solution
and this is exactly what we are trying
to demonstrate here is can we run IOT
etch on a device as small as a raspberry
pie that is a Laura gateway so and in
this gate we do all the Laura logic and
so for IOT obby becomes like normal
Wi-Fi solution so let's take a look at
what we do here
so the lure is composed basically by two
pieces one is called packet for water
it was dust all day networking sunny
sent to a UDP port it does the to raid
your receiving trucks and send it to a
UDP port that's kind of standard most of
the gateway providers support the
standard packet for water mostly they
derive from the same same taxi code and
what we did say all will be cool that we
can manage that right we can centrally
manage from algae ah push it down to the
gateway do settings changes and so on so
we run a container and we run the packet
for water as a docker container on the
raspberry pi the next thing we said okay
now we need a Laura stock and so you can
take some of the open source Laura stock
and so on we wanted to create a super
minimalistic to demonstrate how you
could build a Laura stock on top of IOT
ouch and then what we did so in this
Laura stock why we decided to build our
own simple version is because we can
rely on IOT I have all the things that
already there like device management and
so on so I don't need a second registry
I don't need a database I don't need
anything so it's very simple that part
and then of course we can do decryption
decoding
at the edge it means that I already have
the value in a usable format at the edge
so I can do command and control I can
even have a local visualization I'm
running that and I copped I want to see
the data coming in I'm searching the
rhino in Africa I want to see there I
don't want that it goes to the cloud
over whatever 4G that I don't have right
so that's I can run really on the edge
so let's take a look and let's try to
run some real Laura device experimental
it can work it may not let's see so
let's go back to my I Oh tea up here and
if I go to my IOT arm you can see I have
devices but I have also edge so I can
control the edge of the Gateway and so
on exactly as I'm controlling a normal
device so in fact you can see I can
click it and you will see I can see the
status so it's connected already good at
some connectivity and near the
interesting part
I have already four modules running so I
can control remotely which mode you are
running in the Gateway so already cool I
start to see because most of this Laura
gave me you don't know what they are
doing in this case I know oh they're
running for module 2 are from Microsoft
one is this famous packet for Wagner
samtech see running on a container and
our small dotnet lore ok so there are
other things that we show you how to
configure deploy a new container and so
on that's a cool things but in my case
the first thing I want to prove you that
is really true
so if I connect to my PI and I say dr. P
as you can see I'm running really those
four containers right so now I can take
a look at the logs of one of these one
and I think I have there we go and you
can see there is my mini Laura stack
running and waiting for new messages so
now we want to build Aurora device so
how you build a Laura device on your own
I tell you by a commercial one or when
you buy this kit so this kid goes front
$400 there is verified irradiance on in
all the one Laura device Arduino base
this pretty cool he has a GPS on
so can start already doing GPS tracker
yes the groove thing so you can add
things I add a rotatory I want to
simulate my ranch gateway open close
whatever angle is and you can run on
battery so now we need to write the code
to send this Laura message to the
Gateway the Gateway take it do the
decoding decryption send it upstream so
first thing we need to define this
device right on ilt up so let's go there
on IOT app I'll show yes here devices
and we add these new devices so exactly
as we did for a device coming from
laureate or whatever we do it for our
gateway and in this case it will be call
rotatory whatever name I gave it perfect
so nothing new now there is one more
thing view that I want to do decoding
and decryption and make sure that is for
me I also need to use the key of Laura
and there are two things
ABP or over the are activation right now
I show a BP we will publish also
over-the-air activation and I take my
Laura device and I want to enter the key
so the keys are there I will show you
and I can enter as a device stream so
then we can do the decryption decoding
that's a beauty of using I'll clap I
don't need another database for these
things I can use the twin database for
that and that's exactly what I do and
basically you need a device address is a
MAC address of Laura is not unique to
save bytes this is a bit tricky so
that's why it's so small so you need
additional things to make sure that is
for you and then you have two keys
application as key they keep the payload
networks key checks that the payload is
for me so I can drop package that are
for orders now only a lazy guy like me
the King said both key the same sorry
about the hat but I'm lazy
now I saved that cool I am a key perfect
device is created so now I need to write
they Arduino code for doing that so the
Arduino code is very simple I took the
example I take the Laura one library
that is coming there I have the last
angle the data
the sitar P does lower initialization
the MAC address the device address I put
there those one we are not using here
and then they famous two key that's why
I put the two key because I didn't know
which one is first I didn't have time to
look up so I put the same key very easy
from my side and then say the data rate
we can do it up if data rate I didn't do
it to keep it simple
ready one is ready I'm looping and
checking if there is a degree change
above three degree I'm packaging that
and that's my optimization I send a
string so I don't need to parse it after
even more lazy but I really wanted to
keep it as simple as possible that
people can can start to play with that
and then create an array and then send
it that's it and then I read the angle
so this amount of coding Arduino you
have your first Laura base device so
pretty cool we plug it in on the USB
perfect and now we can go and look into
my King here we do the deployment on my
Arduino board and there we go and so if
I go back here you will see after a
while that there should be new message
coming in if I didn't screw up anything
or this is the moment that I get more
nervous in my session let's see oh there
we go you find the device it decoded
find the angle you find a meek code so
you validate everything and now is
creating a connection through the local
Q through IOT hub and send it all the
upstream so I can do local processing
and upstream so now you can see I can
send some more data and is coming in so
pretty cool so I show you quickly the
code yes I've done perfect just to show
how easy now is a simplified version we
publish a more rich version this is
really to show how simple would be to
create a each module so the H module
body as he has a UDP listener to listen
to this packet for values so they are
communicating inside easy when I get the
listener as soon as I get biased I go to
a processor and the processor
what he does is send advice to this
Laura class that Dussel the Laura magic
and then he gave me back yeah I process
so is a valid package I get the device
address go try to find if the device
address is already my cache if he's not
in the cache I go and query for that so
I can get the keys and I added to the
cache if it's in the cache I said it's
on the cache so I don't need to do this
job for every new message and then I
accept if he's accepting so is valid for
me I do this Mik validation with the
network key to make sure that the
package is really for me
nobody spoofing or sending data this not
for me if it's for me I do even
decryption using the app key so now I
have the decryption and then I do the
decoding so here I do the decoding and
now I have the JSON so that's exactly
what I'm sending out here so this is the
JSON that I get and then I create the
complete JSON with the RSSI and all the
metadata information and sending create
a device so impersonating a Laura like
you will be a wireless device to the LT
up so you can really track per device
and then set it up stream so that's
about it so other than the Laura the
module is very simple so if you want to
do blue to the same things transforming
Bluetooth device to IOT up device you
can create a blue tube reach exactly the
same thing so I'm doing for Laura but
you can do it whatever it is it to be
translated okay cool but you say I want
to show some lower processing locally
something fun so I have an additional
device same board it just has some more
shield so this is not really wearable
but at the intention so what yes is a
temperature sensor and yes I our trade
monitor so hopefully the demo will work
if the air rate goes below zero call
emergency temperature we don't know yet
because we see that it's not good and so
basically it's not really wearable but
that's why school development kit right
and development board is not wearable
but the ideas you could get variable and
plug it in turn it on and this device
already pre-configured
the code is very similar to this one
right is just sending my data so if I go
back to my things here at some point I
should be able to see this device coming
alive sending data or fully my air raid
will be kind of good let's see there we
go I have my irate 129 I'm really fit
right so it's a bit stressful this demo
but probably will get better it's going
down um and at 98 so I'm getting a more
calm you that he works so now we want to
do local processing so to do local
processing I want to maybe install a new
module on this edge so I don't need to
go and try to share into Raspberry Pi
and I have 100 of these Gateway around
the world and so on so the good thing I
can do it I shouldn't talk about this
issue there we go let's keep the monitor
running and now what I want to do I want
to go and deploy a visualization module
so I can go here on my idea edge thingy
click click I do a lot of clicking today
but at least you see some demos and now
I want to set down a new module it could
be an upgrade to a current one but in
this case we don't have it so we add it
so I said set module and in this case I
want to add a new module you can see you
can have stream analytics we will have
machine learning or a simple domain
module or whatever container it doesn't
need to be done that we will have node
we will have Java or you can even run
whatever eggsy
like we do for the packet forward ok now
cool let's call it log visualizer it's
not really a log visualizer but but that
did these things we call it log
visualizer here I take the container
that contain all the engine for that it
comes from my registry this is the
version I have some startup settings so
in this case is the container settings
to expose the ports there there we go
ready save next next submit Patapon is
sending down to edge to say oh you go
grab this docker image download it start
it make it run and the cool thing is
that
you can monitor it from here you can
even create deployment job so if you
want to deploy this module across many
edge devices you can do so you can see
the easy management of this thing
perfect let's see it will take maybe one
or two minutes maybe less to start let's
up the restarts so my rate will go up
and happen up I'm optimistic it works
all the demo so far is almost a record
so let's see work worst case you trust
me
so some died I don't know if when I
reassess much quicker or it's just that
it takes about the same time but you're
in front of people it seems like a
tearing it cool so let's go back here
and try to go to that so now I connect
to the Raspberry Pi what did I do wrong
[Music]
there we go
and this is my module so now he's
getting new data so as soon as I get new
data if you'd show up here hopefully you
see and it should plot the chart so
pretty cool
you can see now my Herod will slowly go
in it's 90 and again it's Laura based
I'm not standing like a million per
second Sun so slowly you get the chart
so you can see I can even get my phone
getting to that let's see if it really
works yeah there we go ISO between a
format but you know I have the same
chart that can pass by the phone no I'm
kidding so you can see I have message
coming in exactly and so I can connect
so I'm connected locally Taurus berry
pie completely offline if I wanted to is
creating a queue so you can see the
power how easy is to create laura device
and send it there so last thing i wanted
to show you because we go to the
conclusion is that view that is a
gps-based solution i decided to take it
yesterday around oslo and see do i get a
bit of a range so I put my Raspberry Pi
in my hotel room seven floor just in
face facing this building seven floor
not 25th on the roof seven floor inside
you cannot even open the window in that
hotel room and then I went for a walk so
if I go and query this data and I go
here and let's go to this one and you
can see this is the plot of the data its
plot the green means a good reception
stop no okay perfect so the green and
you can see I was walking around and see
always kind of cool I can get a
reception around from my hotel and then
I was bored and I decided let's go to
see the Opera so across the train
station of course inside no GPS not
sending and then you can see it even got
down to the Opera House and you can even
see our long he take took me to walk
from here so it was
5:02 to get to the rooftop 5:08 so I'm
not feet at all but I do you figure out
already
with my arraignment just to show you one
gateway even the cheap no again antenna
no rooftop antenna is not that big
distance but across building so one
antenna per building will cover all the
infrastructure that you have Emilia see
that's the power of Laura perfect so too
as a conclusion so you see with every is
fairly easy to create custom IOT
solution you've seen some of the basic
component you can use is fairly easy to
connect Laura one device especially if
the provider I laureate activity the
thing network already have a connector
to IOT up
if not we even sure you can build your
own connector from our REST API most of
this network server can push data to
rest and we can trust on rest to an IOT
up call you can even use our HTTP things
but you know my need to transform Kings
in there you can start with this
solution and pretty soon when we will
ship out yet we will also ship the
sample again is not a fool or a stock
approved by the Lorelei on the Sun it's
really more the idea to Co if I want to
have a simple scenario I want to run it
offline on a really simple I want to
track my small Kings around my house my
vision of these things is that ideal in
the future and hopefully the Laura
network provided they will jump on this
idea is like you buy a or let's say the
gateway provider like you buy a router
today at home right you take the router
you plug it in you go somewhere is a to
configuration you get to the Internet
and the same should be for Laura I buy a
root Gateway plugged in go in IOT ops I
deploy all the
modules Pam and the device start sending
data so that should be the way to do
things so I'm at Don and end of time I
hope you enjoy and you understood a bit
of this technology I'm staying here
why this mantra so so if you have
questions on just a bye
I would like to talk about with people
about all the scenario I will be all day
to more around so stop by you recognize
me for the accent so if you're not sure
talk with me you will feel it that is me
and then we can discuss and come up
maybe with a concrete project that we
can work together thank you very much
for your time enjoy the rest of NDC
[Applause]